الحمد
لله هذه قديمه من قديم الزمان والحمد لله
الزين اللي الزين في الوداع لكل جيل يظهر
ملتزم بذي العاده يعني ما يغيرها احنا
الوداع نودع نستانس نودع رمضان بفرح
ونستقبل
بفرح نهلل نذكر الله ونذكر الرسول ونودع
رمضان ويعني وفنون قديمه وايد مثل الفن
العاشوري هو يتقدم في
حق الوداع وعندنا فنون كثيره
يعني ما عندنا دوات موسقيه الله يسلمك
عندنا طبول الطبل اللي ادون بالوداع
وعندنا الطيران بس هذه الادوات وعندنا
اللي يبد اللي هو يغني يبد وناص
الشيل ها من سنين من اليوم عمري سبع سنوات
احنا نطلع معصب م ه القلالي الوداع والحمد
لله رب العالمين ما انقطع حلويات نسوي
ايام القرعون وايام اول بدايه رمضان نحتفل
نسوي القرعون الكبار والصغار يعني والحمد
لله رب العالمين مستانسين هذه تخلي تماسك
اقوى واقوى شوف الحين الشباب ايش كثرهم
جميع الاجيال من عود وصغير ومر عود وقف عن
بيتهم ورجال كبير يمش ناس في السياك كبار
ما يقدرون يمشون يعني الحمد لله الكل
فرحان بالعكس ها سو عندنا ناس تى بس من
قلالي ناس من جميع مناطق البحرين تشارك
معانا واهلا وسهلا بهم في كل وقت